We'd like to introduce you to the first release of the native HTTP logger coming soon to BurpSuite.
Let's head over to the Logger tab.
Here we can see a list of log items with the request response viewer showing on selection.
At the top we can see the capture filter summary.
This provides a brief overview of what the logger is capturing.
You can see in the summary that the log limit is set to 50 megabytes.
Let's change this by clicking it.
Here we're able to adjust the capture limit.
We can make a selection from the drop down or enter a custom value.
We advise limiting the amount of memory used by the logger so that performance isn't compromised.
Let's set this to 100 megabytes and click apply.
Below the capture filter we can also change the view filters which will refine the data shown in the table below.
Over to the right we can also configure the columns that are shown in the table and we can clear the log by clicking the trash icon.
We can also toggle the logger on and off by clicking the button here.
So that's a simple overview of the logger tool.
This will be available in the early adopter channel for both community and professional versions coming soon.
We'll see you next time.
Bye.
!